why why but most people just think about
this the vast majority of people go
through their lives even all of their
compulsory mathematics education and
even the non-compulsory mouth management
education and they never find out that
there's such a thing as complex numbers
and you can do plenty of mattes in there
like all the way up into extension one
that's not easy stuff and they don't
even know that these thing exists right
so why do we care about them and why are
we going through invest so much and them
because trust me it's gonna get hard ok
that's why it's for you well I'm gonna
try and answer that question for you
first with a simple example my favorite
you do consider so this faithful old
quadratus too many times before okay and
being that it's equal to zero this has a
solution actually it's a pair solution
okay and by now I heard you know what
that pair of solutions is however what
I'd like to point out to you and I'd
like us all to rehearse it together
it is normally you would solve this by
factoring because it's easy to factorize
right but we go through factorizing then
we go through completing the square and
we use completing the square to arrive
at the quadratic formula okay the
quadratic form is great because you know
you can use it on anything even when
it's hard to factorize
so I want to take this and I want to
just use that skill that we know about
the quadratic form I just want apply it
to here we know what the conclusion
movie but let us see what happens as we
go through so fever mean we know the
quadratic form is what numbers and I'm
going to put in minus 5 would just be
plus or minus square root of 5 squared
which is 25 minus 24 AC which is 4 times
1 times 6 which is 24 all over in this
case just two now what I want to point
out to you before we go any further is
that according to the quadratic formula
like the quadratic formula has baked
into it
right it has certs like it's part of the
woman you have to say minus B plus or
minus the square root all you don't say
the square root of then you won't get
the quadratic form in and won't get the
answers now just keep that in the back
of your mind
that's on let's continue 25 minus 24 of
course is why are you squared 1 is 1
okay yes thank you sir I've got that in
there their problems the reason why I
need to worry about the case anyway
right
uh and from here we're gonna get well
the negative case will be minus 5 minus
1 which is minus 6 so you get negative 3
and the positive case will be minus 5
plus 1 which is negative 4 so we get
this solution now this is weird this is
weird the foreigner itself has a cert in
it right but then the Sun disappears
sorry I said that again
okay now what you're talking about is
getting a multiplicity of answers like
how many S's do I get but what I'm
interested in is what kind of answers am
I getting and the answer is I seem to
start off with a sir the formula tells
me to expect a sir but then the sir just
kind of doesn't become a certain just
disappears now this is strange right I
have an answer that's completely
rational right whole numbers even in
this case but to get to these rational
numbers I have to appeal to irrational
numbers but and they just seem to vanish
away now here's the important thing and
this is what starts to answer this
question for us okay this is a quadratic
that if you do know how to quadratic but
if you have a cubic formula right if I'm
a cubic there is a cubic formula that
exists right it's kind of you know it's
analogous to this kind of thing except
it's own Boston plus it's much longer
like takes a whole page to write the
whole thing across but more importantly
the cubic formula it includes it's got
baked into it negative values underneath
the square root signs that appear in it
right there are square root symbols
expressions in the cubic formula just
like they are in the quadratic formula
but by necessity the cubic formula has
negative values under there they have to
be negative okay now this is weird
though because if I give you a cubit
right just considering he's a cubic
okay now this cubic has completely real
roots right what are the roots of this
thing can you help me with them out how
would I commence I can factorize right
excuse me this yes and then I can
factorize one more time to agree with
that which gives me X minus one so this
is a cubic you expect to tap three roots
and there they are and they're all real
roots but in order to get to those
leaves your roots if you want to use the
formula negative values non-real numbers
appear in the formula even than what
your area is completely real does that
make sense in the same way that
irrational numbers appear in here even
if what you get out the other end is
completely rational now this is a very
strange idea and it gets at why numbers
have the names that they do I want you
to recall what were the families are
numbers that are introduced to you
before you remember what their go we'll
start with the natural numbers and what
was next after that we talk about the
integers so we in the claim you think it
is right what happened after that we
talked about rational numbers right
there we went to real numbers and then
we've landed where we are which is the
complex world okay now the important
thing which should have noticed right is
that we know what rational numbers are
and we know what real numbers are but
outside of these right we have numbers
in here that seems
be not rational and seem to be not real
and they've got these strange names we
call these irrational numbers and
imaginary okay if they are not in those
sets okay just ponder this for a second
right if you are not a math student and
you sort of work irrational what would
that mean to you it would be like stop
being irrational it means stop being
crazy
stop like not making sense that's what
rationality or irrationality is and the
whole point is that the reason why that
word means that is because in here it's
like this number doesn't really make
sense it's just stupid it just
disappears anyway but we kind of have to
put it in kind of as a hack right it
just makes the formula work okay it's
not really there it'll disappear but
you've got to put in at some point okay
by the way this is Seidner a book is
alone with me because um it's a really
cool example you guys name the Fibonacci
numbers right the Fibonacci sequence we
have a definition a recursive definition
for it right it needs F 1 and F 2 and
then we can say F n can you help me up
what's that one one that's the first
term F 2 also what okay once you know
that you can write F n what's the end
Fibonacci number it's the previous one
plus the one before that okay now we've
been working with series and sequences
long enough to know if these are
recursive definition there should be
just like a formula definition as well
right we don't need to worry about it
because outside the scope of the course
but it exists it's this disastrous mess
it's possible
good question the question for why it's
Route five has something to do with
something important called the border
ratio but I'm not gonna dig into it okay
now here's the here's the really really
we think as you can see just like with
the quadratic formula you can kind of
understand why surd's are in the
quadratic formula because you know what
we know some quadratics they do have
irrational roots we know that right but
there's not a single Fibonacci number
that has any irrational part to it right
but you have to have irrational you've
gotta have the square root of five in
order to make the formula work for any
value of n any I should say any integer
value of n actually any natural value in
all of these square roots of 5 they all
come out in the wash every single one
they all disappear and that's why you
get this sequence right no square roots
of anything to be seen but in order to
make the formula work we have to appeal
to numbers that seem to be there like a
hack and then they disappear now that's
why these numbers here when you get
negatives under me that's why they
called imaginary in fact the people who
really pioneer in this field they call
them not imaginary numbers but they
called them
fictitious numbers they're numbers that
another feel they're not actually there
but you kind of need to stick it into
your formula so you formula works
question who is interested in such a kid
who is interested in coming up with all
this that made numbers that didn't exist
made them appear and the answer is and
this is so interesting you've got to go
and look it up yourself okay the short
answer is a whole bunch of Italian
mathematician now the one you want to
particularly look for if you once you go
and search this top because it's a
hilarious story as you discover not 10
seconds then what you want to look for
is karma ca RDA and oh very important
Italian mathematician around the 1,500
1,600 1,500
sixteenth century right now the reason
this is such a big deal to them is that
in the Italian mathematical world if you
had like an office as the associate
professor of mathematics was aware that
the way you applied for a job which you
didn't put in a CV and then you had an
interview process if you thought you
were good enough as a mathematician to
take that job you challenged the person
who had the job to a duel right now not
just like any job like the French people
they were all about bang bang tools
right but these are Italian
mathematicians they had mathematical
duels now like I think I'm a better
mathematician than you and this is where
they're doing maybe I look I'm gonna
come with ten questions right and I can
answer them I know the answers to them
I'll give them to you
you give me your ten questions I reckon
I can answer your questions
faster and better than you can answer
mine well as in the point is I will give
you questions that I know it can be
solved cuz I know their solutions right
so you can see in order to win such a
duel there's literally like this
mathematical arms race right now lots of
people believe for a long time that
quadratics could be solved but cubics
could not right so it's like this holy
grail of like if I'm in television right
and I can come up with a cubic formula
it's like it's like the secret weapon
that can shoot down anyone because I'll
give you a cubic and you won't be able
to solve it but I can write so they were
intensely interested in coming up with
different kinds of cubics that can be
solved here for instance monic
quadratics it easier so normally ones
are harder to solve and it's exactly the
same with cubics right so that's why
they pushed really hard into this area
and they forced themselves to deal with
these numbers because that's how they
could get someone else's job right and
there were very very prestigious
positions so you should look up Connor
and his duels and all the people he
fought with and on the secrets that were
around like you know he was one of them
who did one of the tricky things what's
really hilarious is that you know how we
talked about all Pythagoras's theorem
and like theorems that a name not two
people right one of the reasons why a
lot of the results that we have are
named dr. people is because we don't
know who came up with them because they
founders all and instead of publishing
kept it secret because that's your
secret weapon why would you publish yeah
exactly
so people would discover it they would
use it there with all these jewels and
then when they died they would take this
secret with them to the grave and then
someone else someone else decades later
would rediscover it me like oh this is
cool and then you know it was a lot of
detective attack you do so well it just
says something about you okay so so so
so so right can we just come back this
is the question I was trying to add
someone right why did people go to why
do they want to go to like this field of
numbers were just so hard to work with
they are hard to work with as you just
go back um the answer is they didn't
want to they didn't want to go there but
in order to develop the weapons they
needed they were forced to go there
because imaginary numbers they arise
naturally very quickly out of the
regular old counting numbers and the
ways you can combine them algebraically
right you've just got to deal with them
and so they're there and so
mathematicians with it